the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
well what we're going to do today is
climb a pretty big mountain because
we're going to go from a neural net with
two parameters to discussing the kind of
neural nets in which people end up
dealing with 60 60 million parameters so
it's going to be a pretty big jump but
along the way are a couple things I
wanted to underscore from our previous
discussion last time I try to develop
some intuition for the kinds of formulas
that you use to actually do the
calculations in a small neural net about
how the weights are going to change and
the main thing I tried to emphasize is
that when you have a neural net like
this one
everything is sort of divided in each
column you can't have the performance
based on this output effect some weight
change back here without going through
this finite number of output variables
the Y ones but by the way there's no y 2
and y 4 this is there's no y2 and y3
that dealing with this is a really a
notational nightmare and I spent a
little time a lot of time yes straight
trying to clean it up a little bit but
basically what I'm trying to say has
nothing to do with the notation I've
used but rather with the fact that
there's a limited number of ways in
which that can influence this even
though the number of paths through this
network can be growing exponential so
those equations underneath our equations
that are derived from trying to figure
out how the output performance depends
on some of these weights back here and
what I have calculated as I've
calculated the dependence of the
performance on w1 going that way and
account and have also calculated the
dependence on performance performance on
w1 going w1 going that way so that's one
of the equations I've got down there and
another one deals with w3 and it
involves going both this way and this
way and all I've done in both cases in
all four cases is just take the partial
derivative performance with respect to
those weights and use the chain rule to
expand it and when I do that
this is the stuff I get and that's just
a whole bunch of partial derivatives but
if you look at it and then it's sing a
little bit to you what you see is that
there's a lot of redundancy in the
computation so for example this guy here
partial performance with respect w1
depends on both paths of course but look
at the first elements here these guys
right here and look at the first
elements in the expression for
calculating the partial derivative
performance respect to w3 these guys are
the same and not only that if you look
inside these expressions and look at
this particular piece here you see that
that is an expression that was needed in
order to calculate one of the downstream
weights changes one of the downstream
weights what it happens to be the same
thing as you see over here and likewise
this piece is the same is the same thing
you see over here so each time you move
further and further back from the output
store the inputs you're reusing a lot of
computation that you've already done so
I trying to find a way to slogan eyes
this and what I've come up with is
what's done is done and cannot be no no
let's count them not quite right is it
that's um what's computed is computed
and need not be recomputed okay
so that's what's going on here and
that's why this is a calculation that's
linear in the depth the depth of the
neural net not exponential
there's another thing I wanted to point
out in connection with these neural nets
and that has to do with what happens
when we look at a single neuron and note
that what we've got because we've got a
bunch of weights but you're multiplying
times a bunch of inputs like so and then
those are all summed up in a summing box
before they enter some kind of
non-linearity in our case a sigmoid
function but if I ask you to write down
the expression for the value we've got
there what is it well it's just the sum
of the W's times the X's what's that
that's the dot product remember a few
lectures ago I said that some of us
believe that the dot product is a
fundamental calculation that takes place
in our heads so this is why we think so
if neural nets are doing anything like
this then there's a dot product between
some weights and some input values now
it's a funny kind of dot product because
in a models we've been using these input
variables are all or none or 0 or 1 but
that's ok I have a good authority that
there are neurons in our head for which
the values that are produced are not
exactly all or none but rather have a
kind of proportionality to them so you
get a real dot product type of operation
out of that so that's by way of a couple
of the sides that I wanted to underscore
before we get into the center of today's
discussion which will be to talk about
the so-called deep nets now let's see
what's a deep net do well from last time
you know that a deep net does that sort
of thing and it's interesting to look at
some of the some of the offerings here
by the way how good was this performance
in 2012 well it turned out that the
fraction of the time that the system had
the right answer in its top five choices
was about 15% and the fraction of the
time that it got exactly the right
answer as its top pick was about 37
percent error 15 percent error if you
count it as an error if it's what am I
saying
you got it right if you got it in the
top 5 an error rate on that calculation
about 15 percent if you say you only get
it right if you got it if it was your
top choice then the error rate was about
37 percent so pretty good especially
since some of these things are highly
ambiguous even to us and what kind of a
system did that well it wasn't it wasn't
a one that looked exactly like that
although that is the essence of it the
system actually looked like that there's
quite a lot of stuff in there and what
I'm going to talk about is not exactly
this system but I'm going to talk about
the stuff of which such such systems are
made because there's nothing
particularly special about this it just
happens to be a particular assembly of
components that tend to reappear when
everyone when anyone does is sort of
neural net stuff so let me explain that
this way first thing I need to talk
about is the concept of well I don't
like the term it's called convolution I
don't like the term because you know and
in the second-best course if the
Institut signals and systems you learn
about impulse responses and convolution
integrals and stuff like that and this
hints at that but it's not the same
thing because there's no there's no
memory involved in what's going on as
these signals are processed but they
call it convolutional neural Nets anyway
so here you are you've got some kind of
image and even with lots of computing
power and GPUs and all that sort of
stuff we're not talking about images
with the you know four thousand four
million pixels we're talking about
images that might be 256 on the side
let's say we're not talking about images
that are a thousand by a thousand or
four thousand by four thousand anything
like that they tend to be a kind of
compressed into 256 by 256 image and now
what we do is we run over this with a
neuron that is looking only at a 10 by
10 square like so and that produces an
output and next we run over that again
having shifted this neuron a little bit
like so and then the next thing we do is
we shift it again so I get that output
right there so each of those deployments
of a neuron produces an output and that
output is associated with a particular
place in the image this is a process
that is called the convolution as a term
of art this guy this convolution
operation results in a bunch of points
over here and the next thing that we do
with those points is we look in local
neighborhoods and see what the maximum
value is and then we take that maximum
value and construction yet another
mapping of the image over here using
that maximum value then we slide that
all over like so and we produce another
value then we slide that value then we
slide that over one more time the
different color and now we've got yet
another value so this process is called
Puli
and because we're taking the maximum
this particular kind of pulling is
called max point so now let's see what's
next
this is taking a particular neuron and
running across the image but maybe there
are lots of we call that a kernel again
sucking some terminology out of signals
and systems but now what we're going to
do is we're going to say we're going to
we could we can use a whole bunch of
kernels so the thing that I produce with
one kernel can now be repeated many
times like so in fact a typical number
is a hundred times so now what we've got
is we've got a 256 by 256 image we've
gone over it with a 10 by 10 Colonel
we've taken the maximum value of values
that are in the vicinity of each other
and then we repeated that 9600 times so
now we can take that and we can feed all
those results into some kind of neural
net and then we can do perhaps a fully
connected job on the final layers of
this and then that in the ultimate
output we get some sort of indication of
how likely it is that the thing that's
being seen is say a mite so that's
roughly how these things work so what do
we talked about so far we've talked
about pooling and we've talked about
convolution and now we can talk about
some of the good stuff but before I get
into that this is what we can do now and
and and you can compare this with what
was done in the old days
it was done in the old days before
massive amounts of computing became
available is a kind of real net activity
that's a little easier to see you might
in the old days only have enough
computing power to deal with a small
grid of picture elements or so-called
pixels and then each of these might be a
value that is fed as an input into some
kind of neuron and so you might have a
column of neurons that are looking at
these pixels in your in your in your
image and then there might be a small
number of columns that follow from that
and finally something that says this
neuron is looking for things clicks are
a number one that is to say something
that looks like another one in the image
so this stuff up here is is what you can
do when you have a massive amount of
computation relatives the kind of thing
you used to see in the old days so
what's different well what's different
is instead of a few hundred parameters
we've got a lot more instead of ten
digits we have a thousand classes
instead of a few hundred samples we have
maybe a thousand examples of each class
so that makes a million samples and we
got sixty million parameters to play
with and the surprising thing is that
the net result is we've got a function
approximator that astonishes everybody
and no one quite knows why it works
except that when you throw an immense
amount of computation into this kind of
arrangement it's possible to get
performance that no one expected would
be possible so that's sort of the bottom
line but now there are a couple of ideas
beyond that that I think are especially
interesting and I want to talk about
though
first idea that's especially interesting
is the idea of Auto coding and here's
how the idea of Auto coding works
I'm going to run out of board space so I
think I'll do it right here you have
some input values they go into a layer
of neurons the input layer then there is
a so-called hidden layer that's much
smaller so maybe there are in the
example they'll be ten neurons here and
just a couple here and then these expand
to an output layer like so now we can
take the output layer C 1 through Zn and
compare it with a is the desired values
d1 through TN you follow me so far now
the trick is to say well what are the
desired values let's let the desired
values be the input values so we're
going to do is we're going to Train this
net up so the outputs the same as the
input what's good of that but we're
going to force it down through this neck
down piece of network so if this network
is going to succeed in taking all the
possibilities here and cramming them
into this smaller inner layer this
so-called hidden layer such that they it
can reproduce the input at the output it
must be doing some kind of
generalization of the kinds of things
that sees on its input and that's a very
clever idea and it's seen in various
forms in a large fraction of the papers
that appear on deep neural nets but now
I want to talk about an example so I can
show you a demonstration okay so we
don't have GPUs and we don't have three
days to do this so I'm going to make it
make up a very simple example that's
reminiscent of what goes on here but but
involves hardly any copy
what I'm going to imagine is we're
trying to recognize animals from how
tall they are from the shadows that they
cast so we're going to recognize three
animals a cheetah a zebra and a giraffe
and they will each cast a shadow on a
blackboard like me
no no vampire involved here and what
we're going to do is we're going to use
the shadow as a input to a neural net
all right so let's see how that would
work so there is our network and if I
just click into one of these test
samples that's the height of the shadow
that ochita casts on a wall and there
are 10 input neurons corresponding to
each level of the shadow their rim
through 3 inner layer neurons and from
that it spreads out and becomes the
outer layer values and we're going to
compare those outer layer values to the
desired values but the desired values
are the same as the input values so this
column is a column of input values on a
far right we have our column of desired
values and we haven't trained as an
owner yet all we've got is random values
in there so if we run the test samples
through we get that and that yeah
cheetahs are short zebras are medium
height and giraffes are tall but our
output is just pretty much 0.5 for all
of them for all of those shadow Heights
all right
no training so far so let's run this
thing we're just using simple backdrop
just like just like on our world
simplest neural net and it's interesting
to see that what happens is you see all
those values changing now I need to
mention that when you when you see a
green connection that means it's a
positive weight and the green density of
the green indicates how positive it is
and the red ones are negative weights
and the intensity of the red indicates
how red it is so here you can see that
we still have from from our random
inputs a variety of red and green values
we
haven't really done much training so
everything correctly looks pretty much
random so let's run this thing and after
only a thousand iterations going through
these examples and trying to make the
output the same as the input we reached
a point where the error rate has dropped
in fact it's dropped so much it's
interesting to relook at the test cases
so here's a test case where we have a
cheetah and now the output value is in
fact very close to the desired value and
all and all the output in all the output
neurons so if we look at another one
once again there's a correspondence and
write two columns and if we look at the
final one yeah there's a correspondence
in the right two columns knowing you
back up from this and say well what's
going on here it turns out that you're
not training this thing to classify
animals you're training it to understand
the nature of the things that it sees in
the environment because all it sees is
the height of a shadow doesn't know
anything about the classifications
you're going to try to get out of that
all it sees is that there are there's a
kind of consistency and the kind of data
that it sees on the input values all
right now you might say okay oh that's
cool because what must be happening is
that that hidden layer because
everything is forced through that narrow
pipe must be doing some kind of
generalization so it ought to be the
case that if we click on each of those
neurons we ought to see it specialized
to a particular height because that's
what sorts of stuff that's the sort of
stuff that's presented on the input well
let's go see what is what in fact is the
maximum stimulation to be seen on the
neurons in that hidden layer so if I
when I click on these guys what we're
going to see is the input values that
maximally stimulate that neuron and by
the way I have no idea how this is going
to turn out because it's all you know
the initialization is all random well
that's good that one looks like it's
generalized the notion of
short that doesn't look like medium in
fact the maximum stimulation doesn't
involve any stimulation from that lower
neuron here look at this one that
doesn't look like tall so we got one
that looks like short and to look just
look really random
so in fact maybe we'd better back off
the idea that what's going on in that
hidden layer is generalization and say
that what's going on in there is maybe
the encoding of a generalization it
doesn't look like a encoding we can see
but there is an encoding there is a
generalization that's where you start
that over we don't see the
generalization in the stimulating values
what we have instead is we have some
kind of encoded generalization and
because we got this stuff in CODIS what
makes these neural nets so
extraordinarily difficult to understand
we don't just don't understand what
they're doing we don't understand why
they can recognize a cheetah we don't
understand why it can recognize a school
bus in some cases but not in others
because we don't really understand what
these neurons are responding to well
that's not quite true there's been a lot
of work recently on try not to sort that
out but it's still a lot of mess mystery
in this world in any event I see that's
the auto coding idea it comes in various
guises sometimes people talk about
Boltzmann machines and things of that
sort but it's basically all the same
sort of idea and so you can do this
layer by layer
once you've trained the input layer then
you can use that layer to train the next
layer and then that can train the next
layer after that and it's only at the
very very end that you say to yourself
well now I've accumulated a lot of
knowledge about that environment and
what can be seen in the environment
maybe it's time to get around to using
some some samples of particular classes
and train on training on classes so
that's the story on auto coding now the
next thing to talk about
is that final layer so let's see what
the final layer might look like let's
see it's a it might look like this
there's a summer there's a minus one up
here let's see there's a minus one up
here back there's a minus one up there
there's a multiplier here and there's a
threshold value there likewise there's
some other input values here let me call
this one X and it gets multiplied by
some weight and then that goes into the
summer as well and that in turn goes
into a summing into a sigmoid that looks
like so and finally you get an output
which we'll call Z so it's clear that if
you just write out the value of Z as it
depends on those inputs now using the
formula that we work with last time and
what you see is that Z is equal to 1
over 1 plus e to the minus W times X
minus t plus T I guess all right
so that's a sigmoid function that
depends on the value of that weight and
on the value of that threshold so let's
look at how that those values might
change things so here we have an
ordinary sigmoid and what happens if we
shift it with the threshold value if we
change that threshold value then it's
going to shift the place where that
sigmoid comes down so the change in T
could cause this thing to shift over
that way and if we change the value of W
that could change how steep this guy is
so we might think that the performance
since it depends on W and T should be
adjusted in such a way as to make the
classification to the right thing but
what's the right thing well that depends
on the samples that we've seen
suppose for example that this is our
sigmoid function and we see some
examples of a class some positive
examples of a class that have values
that lie at that point and that point at
that point and we have some values that
correspond to situations where the class
is not one of the things that are
associated with this neuron and in that
case what we see is examples that are
over on this machine abhi here so the
probability that we would see this
particular guy in this world is
associated with the value on the sigmoid
curve so you can think of this is the
probability of that positive example and
this is the probability of that positive
example and this is the probability of
that positive example what's the
probability of this negative example
well it's 1 minus the value on that
curve and this one's 1 minus the value
on that curve so we could go through the
calculations and what we would determine
is that to maximize the probability of
seeing this data is this particular
stuff in a set of experiments to
maximize that probability we would have
to adjust T and W so as to get this
curve doing the optimal thing and it's
nothing mysterious about it it's just
more partial derivatives in that sort of
thing but the bottom line is that the
probability of seeing this data is
dependent on the shape of this curve and
shape of this curve is dependent on
those parameters and if we want to
maximize the probability that we've seen
this data then we have to adjust those
parameters accordingly let's have let's
have a look at a demonstration
okay so there's an ordinary sigmoid
curve here a couple positive examples
here's a negative example let's put in
some more positive examples over here
and now let's run a good old gradient
descent algorithm on that and this is
what happens you see how the probability
as we adjust the shape of the curve the
probability of seeing those examples of
the class goes up and the probability of
seeing the non-example goes down so what
if we put some more examples in if we
put a negative example there not much is
going to happen but what happened if we
put a positive example right there then
we're going to start seeing some
dramatic shifts in the shape of the
curve
so that's probably a noise point but we
can put some more negative examples in
there and see how that adjusts the curve
all right so that's what we're doing
we're viewing this output value as
something that's related to the
probability of seeing a class and we're
adjusting the parameters on that output
layer so as to maximize the probability
of the sample data that we've got in
hand all right now there's one more
thing
we can see what we've got here is we've
got the basic idea of back propagation
which has layers and layers of
additional let me be flattering and call
them ideas layered on top so here's the
next here's the next idea that's layered
on top so we've got an output value here
and it's a function after all and it's a
it's got a value and we're going to have
a if we have a thousand classes we're
going to have a thousand output neurons
and each is going to be producing some
kind of value and we can think of that
value as a probability but what it
really but I don't want to write a
probability I just want to say that but
we've got for this output neuron is a
function of class 1 and then there will
not be another output neuron which is a
function of class 2 and these values
will be presumably higher this will be
higher if we are in fact looking at
class 1 and this one down here will be
in fact higher if we're looking at class
n so what we'd like to do is we'd like
to not just pick one of these outputs
and say well you're the your that you've
got the highest value so you win what we
want to do instead is we want to give
some sort we want to associate some kind
of probability with each of the classes
because after all we want to do things
like find the most probable 5 so what we
do is we say all right so the actual
probability of class 1
is equal to the output of that sigmoid
function divided by the sum over all
functions so that takes them all that
entire output vector and converts each
output value into probability so when we
use that sigmoid function we did it with
a view toward thinking about that as a
probability in fact we assumed it was a
probability when we made this argument
but in the end there's there's such now
there's now put for each of those
classes and so what we get is in the end
not exactly a probability until we
divide by a normalizing factor so this
by the way is called this by the way is
called not on my list of things but it
soon will be
since we're not talking about taking the
maximum and identifying the and using
that to classify the picture what we're
going to do is we're going to say we're
going to use what's called soft max so
we're going to give a range of
classifications and we're going to
associate a probability with each and
that's what that's what you saw in all
of those samples you saw yes this is a
container ship but maybe it's also this
that or a third or fourth or fifth thing
so that is a pretty good summary of the
kinds of things that are involved but
now we've got one more step because what
we can do now is we can take this output
layer idea the softmax idea and we can
put it together with the autocoding idea
so we've trained this the middle layer
up and now we're going to detach it from
the output layer but retain those
weights that connect the input to the
hidden layer and when we do that what
we're going to see is something that
looks like this and now we've got a
trained first layer but an untrained
output layer we're going to freeze the
input layer and train the output layer
using that that that so-called that
sigmoid curve let's see what happens
when we do that oh by the way that's
what our test samples through you can
see it's not doing anything the output
is half for each of the categories even
though we've got to train the middle
layer so we have to train the outer
layer let's see how long it takes well
that was pretty fast
now there's a extraordinarily good match
between the outputs and the desired
outputs so that's a combination of the
auto coding idea and the softmax idea
there's get one more idea
that's where they mentioned and that's
the idea of dropout the plague of any
neural net is that it gets stuck in some
kind of local maximum so it was
discovered that these things train
better if on every iteration you you
flip a coin for each neuron and if the
coin ends up tails you assume it's just
died and has no influence on the output
it's called dropping out those neurons
and in the next iteration you drop out a
different set so what this seems to do
is it seems to get this thing from
prevent this thing from going into a
frozen local maximum state so that's
deepness they should be called by the
way wide nets because they tend to be
enormous lis wide but rarely more than
ten layers 10 layers 10 columns deep now
let's see where to go from here maybe
what we should do is talk about the
awesome curiosity in the current state
of the art and that is that all of this
sophistication with output layers that
are probabilities and training using
Auto coding or Boltzmann machines it
doesn't seem to help much relative to
plain old back propagation so back
propagation with a convolutional net
seems to do just about as good as
anything and we're all while we're on
the subject of ordinary deep net i'd
like to examine a situation here where
we have a deep net well it's not real is
over it's a classroom deep net and we'll
put five layers in there
and this job is still to do the same
thing it's to classify an animal as a
cheetah zebra or a giraffe
based on the height of the shadow it
casts and as before if it's green that
means positive if it's red that means
negative and right at the moment we have
no training so if we run our test
samples through the output is always a
half no matter what the animal is all
right
so we're going to do is just going to
use ordinary back prop on this same
thing is in that sample that's
underneath the black board only now
we've got a lot more parameters we've
got five columns and each one of them
has nine or ten neurons in it so let's
let this one run now look at that stuff
on the right it's all turned red at
first I thought this was a bug in my
program but you know it makes absolute
sense if you don't know what the actual
animal is going to be and a whole bunch
of possibilities you better just say no
for everybody just like when the
biologist says we don't know it's the
most probable answer about but
eventually after about 160,000
iterations it seems to have got it let's
run the test samples through that's
doing great let's do it again just to
see if this is a flu
all right on the right side
finally as you start seeing some changes
go in the final layers there and if you
look at the error rate down at the
bottom you see that it kind of kind of
falls off a cliff
so nothing happens for a real long time
and it falls off a cliff now what would
happen if this neural network not quite
so wide good question but before we get
to that question what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do it a funny kind of
variation on the theme of dropout what
I'm going to do is I'm going to kill off
one neuron in each column and then see
what if I can retrain the network to do
the right thing so I'm going to reassign
those to some other purpose so now
there's one fewer neuron in the network
we rerun that we see that it trains
itself up very fast so we seem to be
still close enough to the solution we
can do without one you know one of the
neurons in each column let's do it again
yeah it goes up a little bit but it
quickly falls down to a solution try
again quickly falls down to a solution
oh my god how much is this am I going to
do each time I knock something out and
retrain it finds a solution very fast
well I got all the way down to two
neurons in each column and it still has
a solution it's interesting I think but
let's repeat the experiment but this
time we're going to do it a little
differently
I take our five layers and we're going
to before we do any training I'm going
to knock out all but two neurons in each
column now I know that would turn
neurons in each column I've got it a
solution I just showed it I just showed
one let's run it with this way
it looks like increasingly bad news
what's happened is that this suckers got
itself into a local maximum so now you
can see why there's been a breakthrough
in this neural net learning stuff and
it's because when you widen the net you
turn local Maxima into saddle points so
now it's got a way of crawling its way
through this vast space without getting
stuck on a local maximum as suggested by
this alright so those are some think
interesting things to look at by way of
these demonstrations but now I'd like to
go back to my slide set and show you
some examples that will address the
question of whether these things are
seeing like we see
so you can try these examples online
there are a variety of websites that
allow you to put in your own picture and
there is a cottage industry of producing
papers in journals that fool neural nets
so in this case a very small number of
pixels have been changed you don't see
the difference but it's enough to take
it take this particular neural net from
a high confidence that it's looking at a
school bus to to thinking that it's not
a not a school bus those are some things
that thinks are a school bus so it
appears to be the case that what is
triggering this school bus result is
that it's seeing enough local evidence
that this is not one of the other 999
classes and enough positive evidence
from these local looks to conclude that
it's a school bus
so do you see any of those things I
don't hear you can say okay look at that
baseball one yeah that looks like it's
got a little bit of baseball texture in
it
so maybe what it's doing is looking at
texture these are some examples from a
recent and very famous paper by Google
which use it essentially the same ideas
to put captions on pictures so the thing
that this by the way is what has
stimulated all this enormous concern
about artificial intelligence because a
naive viewer looks at that picture and
says oh my god this thing knows what
it's like to play or be young or move or
what a frisbee is and of course it knows
none of that it just knows how to label
this picture and to the credit of people
wrote this paper they show examples that
don't do so well so yeah it's a cat but
it's not lying I was a little girl but
she's not blowing bubbles what about
this one so we've been doing our own
work in my laboratory on on some of this
and the way the following set of
pictures was introduced was this you
take an image and you separate it into a
bunch of slices representing each
representing a particular frequency band
and then you go into one of those
frequency bands and you knock out a
rectangle for the picture and then you
reassemble the thing and if you hadn't
knocked that piece out when you
reassemble it it would look exactly like
it did when you started so what we're
doing is we knock out as much as we can
and still retain that neural Nets
impression that it's the thing that it
started out thinking it was so what do
you think this is it's identified by a
neural net as a railroad car because
this is the image that it started with
how about this one that's easy right
that's a guitar we weren't able to
mutilate that one very much and still
retain the guitar nests of it
how about this one what's that what a
lamp any other ideas
Ken what do you think it is see he's an
expert on this subject
there's identified as a barbell what's
that
what cello you didn't see the little
girl or the instructor how about this
one what it's a grasshopper
what's this wow you're good
it's actually not a two-headed wolf so
two wolves they're close together that's
a bird right good for you it's a rabbit
what that Russian Wolfhound
if you've been to Venice you recognize
this so bottom line is that these things
are an engineering marvel and do great
things but they don't see like we see